MICHAEL MCDONALD: Good
morning, everyone.
MYLES BORINS: Good morning.
Thanks for coming.
MICHAEL MCDONALD: Hopefully
everyone enjoyed the keynote.
We are here to
present how Serverless
helps you build highly
scalable and secure apps.
So I'm joined onstage
by Myles Borins.
He's the developer advocate
on Google Cloud platform
and he is also a member of
the Node JS Technical Steering
Committee and he also
triages all of the bugs that
come in about Node.
So if you're finding
bugs about Node,
he is the man determining if
they are serious or otherwise.
MYLES BORINS: Hopefully right.
MICHAEL MCDONALD:
Hopefully right.
MYLES BORINS: This is Michael
McDonald, the product manager
here at Google.
Done work on Firebase and GCP.
A lot of our recent
security products
were things that
Michael was working on.
We're really excited
to talk to you today
all about doing
Serverless on Cloud
and how some of the products
that Michael's been working on
and some of our partners
have been working on
will help you write
secure applications.
MICHAEL MCDONALD: Cool.
So how many people feel like
they are security experts?
Anyone raise their hand?
Couple people.
Yeah, I don't even
feel this way.
So we're going to actually
start kind of from foundations
and talk about what is
a threat environment
and go over common
vulnerabilities
or common threats that
your app may face.
So hopefully you'll walk
out of this, if you're not
feeling like you're an
expert at the end of it,
hopefully you'll feel at
least a little more confident.
We'll also be talking about
in the traditional world
what those threats look
like and how they translate
into a Serverless world.
Serverless does a lot
of things automatically,
but there are still
some things that you're
going to have to do.
And lastly, we'll
also talk about how
Google Cloud and in particular
Google Cloud Serverless
offerings make a
lot of that easy.
And in the places that we
don't automatically do for you,
we have some partners
and other vendors
that will come up on
stage and demonstrate
how their tools can help
make your apps more secure.
As a bit of a high level
overview, a couple of things.
One, we have the camera emoji.
That means pull out your
phone and take a picture
or otherwise make a
mental note of it.
But the first important link
that we're going to be sharing
is Node Sec Roadmap.
So if you go to this link it
has a ton of different threats.
A lot of them are kind
of specific or kind
of in the context of Node JS,
but the threats themselves
are general and can
apply to whatever
language or environment
you're running in.
So we're going to be using Node.
We obviously have some pretty
deep technical expertise there,
but it should apply to whatever
language you're working in.
MYLES BORINS: So we just use
the term threat environment.
And you're probably wondering,
what is a threat environment?
Here's the definition from a
software engineer Mike Samuel.
He's actually the engineer
who put together the Node Sec
Roadmap that we just showed.
A threat environment is a
set of targets under attack
and the tools that might
be used to get at them.
It's important to know
that different targets are
vulnerable to different
tools in different ways.
So an application running
on one type of provider
is going to be vulnerable
to different types of tools
than an application running
in another environment.
If you're running an
application in a virtual machine
that you are maintaining
yourself on your own silicon,
there is a different
threat environment
than if you're running
something on App Engine.
And knowing that
threat environment
helps you know
what tools you need
to have to protect
yourself from attack.
So we're going to talk about
a couple of different threats
today.
Quickly listing them
off, we're going
to talk about zero days;
malicious and low quality code;
remote code execution;
denial of service,
classically referred
to as a DOS;
we'll talk about
leaked credentials;
we'll talk about data
exfiltration; query injection;
and one of my favorites, which
doesn't always make these lists
for developer experience.
We'll dig into that in a bit.
MICHAEL MCDONALD: Cool.
So we decided the best way of
showing common vulnerabilities
is to build a really terrible
app and show it to you.
So Myles went on vacation
over this past weekend
and I was hounding him
ceaselessly on Friday afternoon
to build an application for
our demo, and he of course
just wants to go on vacation.
So he actually builds the app
on the way back from Tahoe.
So it's like a three,
four hour drive,
he hacked together
a bunch of functions
to build a content
management solution.
And obviously, written any code
written in the back of a car
is bound to be
absolutely horrific.
So he has saved
mark down function.
By the way, if no one
is familiar with it,
we're using Cloud Functions.
So Cloud Functions is Google
Cloud's platforms functions
as a service offering,
which is kind
of the prototypical
Serverless offering.
And so he wrote a function
that takes in mark down,
converts it to HTML and
writes it to Cloud SQL.
And then we have
another function
that conserve that
HTML from Cloud SQL.
We're actually even just going
to focus on that first function
because trust me there are a
lot of things wrong with it.
MYLES BORINS: So this is fun.
You might think that we're
just making a fun joke,
but I legitimately wrote this
in the car on the way home
from Tahoe.
And before we dive
into the code I'm just
going to show you that this
is live and it actually works.
This is the payload
that we're sending.
It's right in the body like any
good post request should do.
The author is my name.
The title, Oh my God, the
haxors are at it again.
And the markdown,
drop tables lol.
We're going to go and
post that and we're
going to have a response
from the database.
Because your raw
database response
is what you should
always be returning.
And we could see
that this works.
So let's take a look at
the source really quickly.
You could see that we're
promisifying stuff.
Because we're using
Node 8, which we just
announced yesterday, which means
we can use async await, which
I absolutely adore.
We have all of our
credentials in line
so we never have to look
at that piece of paper
that I have on my desk.
We immediately create a
connection to the pool.
We're doing this with
creating a pool for the MySQL
direct connection so that it
will be able to pool resources
when we have multiple
functions go up
and be able to reconnect if
we have any connection issues.
This is also another feature
that we just announced.
You can do direct connect
from Cloud Functions now.
In the make post async function
here, we're going to go,
we're going to convert
the markdown that's
been sent to us into HTML.
We're going to make
a new data object.
We're going to post directly in.
You can see all the information
that we're doing in line here.
Nice and sanitized, or not.
Then we're going to
promise returning it.
And we just do a
little try catch here
where we await the
results of make post.
And then we respond with
the results themselves.
Back to the slides.
MICHAEL MCDONALD:
There are definitely
some issues with that.
MYLES BORINS: Yeah.
MICHAEL MCDONALD:
So the first thing
that we're going to talk
about, if we were completely
unaware of these
vulnerabilities,
we might run into something
called the zero day.
So how many people are
familiar with zero days?
Couple people?
OK, half the room.
So normally when
you have a threat,
you have this thing called
the window of vulnerability.
So from the time that the
vulnerability is disclosed,
ideally someone sends the email
to security at your company
.com and says, hey, I
think there's an issue.
Hopefully they're not selling
it on the internet to someone
else who's going to
go and exploit that,
but ideally in the best
case you the vendor
get that information.
You tell your engineers,
or you go and patch
that vulnerability yourself.
And ideally, you can actually
patch the vulnerability
and get users to apply it
before any exploit is actually
found or used.
But if the exploit is active
before things are fixed,
you have this window
of vulnerability,
your kind of danger
zone of when users
are likely to encounter it.
In a zero day, that's
entirely flipped.
The whole premise
of a zero day is
the exploit is actually
active and out in the wild
before anyone knows about it.
Or you become immediately
aware on day zero
that there is a problem.
And then you have to scramble
to go and fix all of your code
and hopefully get
users to update it.
So how do you stay ahead of
what zero days potentially
exist to avoid those?
MYLES BORINS: So acronyms.
We're at a Google
conference so we
have lots of acronyms for you.
CVE, CNA CWE.
So the first one, CVE,
the common vulnerability
and exposures.
This is a numerated list
that you can get from MITRE.
Every single CVE is a number
that you can go and look up.
It will give you the name
of the dependency or project
that has a vulnerability and
what that vulnerability is.
With a CVE number we're able
to know what's going on.
If you're running
a certain project,
like Node in
production for example,
you can cross-reference
against known CVEs,
and know if the version that
you're using is vulnerable
or not, and what vulnerabilities
you're vulnerable to.
You have a CNA, which is
a CVE numbering authority.
This is who assigns a CVE
number to a vulnerability.
In the Node project,
for example,
we actually get pre-assigned
blocks of CVEs from MITRE
directly and act as our own
CNA associating CVE numbers
with vulnerabilities
as we discover them.
Before we became a CNA, we were
actually using MITRE directly
as a CNA.
So every time a
new vulnerability
was about to be
disclosed, we would
write MITRE with
that information
and then they would get
back to us with a number.
This actually resulted
in times where
we would have to put the patch
out before we had the number
and update with the
number later, which
was why we went through the
process of becoming a CNA.
The third one that
we have there,
CWE, a common
weakness enumeration.
CWE are a list of
numbers that you
can use to reference
certain types
of vulnerabilities and known
patterns that are problematic.
So if you are a
security researcher,
you may use a CWE
when reporting.
So for example, using
all these in a sentence,
an open source project
can use the MITRE CNA
to issue a CVE for a
patched vulnerability.
When a security researcher
reports a vulnerability,
they may include a relevant CWE.
MICHAEL MCDONALD: Awesome.
Thanks, Myles.
MYLES BORINS:
These links up here
go to CVE and CWE, which
are both on mitre.org.
So you can go through and look
at what CVEs are out there,
what you have to worry about.
And if you're thinking
about reporting things,
you can go to the CWE to
include a CWE with your report
to a project when you're
reporting a vulnerability.
So vulnerabilities go all
the way down the stack.
When we start off
and think about it,
you have your hardware.
I'm not going to talk about some
of the hardware vulnerabilities
that happened
recently because they
caused me existential
dread, so we're
going to move up the stack.
And that moves to
the operating system.
These can be vulnerabilities
in things like Linux,
it could be in POSIX itself.
We had a really fun
one back in the day
with Real Path 3 in Node.
Find me later, I'll
tell you about that one.
We move up the stack and we
move to our language runtime.
This is Node itself.
There may be
vulnerabilities in Node,
such as regular expression DoSes
which we've had in the past
and patched fairly recently.
You move up the
stack and you're now
into your dependencies,
everything
that you've installed via NPM.
We've seen some
recently and we'll
dig in to vulnerabilities
that could affect you
via your dependencies.
And finally you reached
the top of your stack,
you reach your application,
and it's possible
that you're writing your
own vulnerabilities.
The thing it's important
to see about this
all the way down
is like, while you
need to be managing your
own application code
and making sure that your
team is writing secure code,
there is a lot of
stuff underneath you
that can be causing
you to be vulnerable
in a transparent way.
You may have no idea.
Now, a great thing
about running Serverless
is that everything below your
dependencies is managed by us.
So if you deploy something
to Cloud Functions
or you deploy something
to App Engine standard,
whenever we get
notified of new CVEs
whenever new patches
are available,
we're able to patch the language
runtime, the operating system,
and even replace the
hardware from under you
without any downtime
or you having
to make any changes on your end.
When the Node project does
a new security release,
we are, in a timely
manner, updating
all of the functions
that are already
deployed so the next time
that it runs it's not
going to be vulnerable.
This is one of the advantages
to using Serverless.
So one of the things
that we talked about
are the dependencies,
which is bringing
in malicious or low quality
code into your project.
So there's lots of ways
that this can get in.
You can have malicious code.
This is code that
is explicitly trying
to be malicious and do
things like pulling things
from pastebin.
You can have low
quality dependencies.
These are just packages that
weren't very well designed
and introduce unexpected
bugs and performance
problems into your code.
Regular expression DoSes are
some of the most active ones
that you'll find here.
And also unintended requires.
It's possible that you
unintentionally require things
into your project because
of dynamic dependencies.
So one of the things that
bad dependencies may do
or even may happen in your own
code is remote code execution.
How many people in
the audience are
shipping eval in production?
MICHAEL MCDONALD: Or the
equivalent in your language.
MYLES BORINS: And
you may actually
be shipping eval and
not even realizing it.
If you're using VM run in
this context or any of the VM
objects in Node, that
actually is still
sharing the same context.
And you may be leaking
and changing your context
if you're running
unsanitized or unknown code.
So remote code execution,
an example of this
actually happened
fairly recently
with the ESLint
security incident.
Is anyone familiar with it?
So last week,
ESLint scope module
was hijacked to steal
NPMRC credentials.
One of the maintainers
of the ESLint project
had their machine compromised.
The person who
compromised the machine
then published a new version
of the ESLint scope module
as a patch update.
The ESLint scope module
was dependent by ESLint.
And if any of you
write JavaScript,
ESLint is the most
widely used tool
for linting code, which
is the way that we
know that we write errors
because dynamic languages are
fun.
So when this
vulnerability happened,
the credentials were stolen,
malicious code was published.
That malicious code was
pulling down a pastebin link
and then executing it via eval.
And at that point, it was
then uploading credentials
or attempting to
upload credentials
to a centralized service.
This is what's
formally known as worm.
It was compromised
and then trying
to compromise other packages
and spread across the ecosystem.
There's a couple
of different ways
that we could
defend against this.
If you were using
explicit lock files,
you wouldn't have updated
to the patch version
if you were sticking
to the lock file.
And if you had had two factor
authentication turned on
on your account, the worm
will not be able to spread.
Because when it
tried to publish,
it would be asking
for your credentials.
I think this is a really
great example of where
the inconvenience of 2FA
pays off in the not having
all of your modules stolen.
So this was how the
attacker did it.
They modified the package JSON
in both ESLint scope and ESLint
config, adding a
post install script
that ran this lib build.js.
And lib bill.js called
an hdbs get on pastebin,
got the information,
and avowed it.
This right here, that line
is why the worm did not
spread as wide as it could.
Generally in Node when
you're doing something.on,
you want to be concatenating
the entire string
and then do on end
to evaluate it.
What we can tell
from this attack,
though, is that we had a really
sophisticated attacker who
just was not well-versed
in the Node APIs.
So thankfully this caused
a whole bunch of crashes
to happen.
And then those
crashes, when it tried
to avow CNC wasn't a full string
it was how people noticed it
within 10 minutes.
And this is, I think, one
of the really great examples
of how on top of it
the Node community is.
Because the second that
people knew about it,
everyone knew about it.
And things were
getting locked down.
And to come talk
a little bit more
about this and some
ways of protecting
your projects we have CJ
Silverio, the CTO of NPM.
Quick round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi, CJ.
How are you doing today?
CJ SILVERIO: Pretty good.
You told me it was a story about
a week that I had was not so
good, but it's good now.
MYLES BORINS: Thankfully
we talked about it before.
CJ SILVERIO: Yeah.
MYLES BORINS: So CJ's going
to come up and demo something.
CJ's in our insecure project
that we were just showing you
where I brought in a whole bunch
of dependencies really quickly.
And CJ, what are you
going to do for us today?
CJ SILVERIO: I'm
going to show you
how we help you close that gap
between when a vulnerability is
found, it's been patched,
but you're still not
in the green zone because
you don't know about it
and you haven't applied
that patch to your project.
So I'm going to demonstrate a
really pretty nifty new thing
that we've done at NPM
to allow you to find out
how to do something about
this without interrupting
your normal workflow.
Here I'm in Myles'
insecure project,
and I'm just going to run
NPM install like I always do.
Maybe I'm installing
a new dependency,
maybe I'm just running
install to do development.
Oh, holy high severity, Batman.
I have a high
security vulnerability
that I didn't know about.
So now I can find out more
information about that
if I want.
Notice I didn't do anything
special to find out.
Now I'm going to
run a new command
for NPM called NPM audit.
Here I find that
marked, the library
I've been using to render
my markdown for my app,
has a regular expression
denial of service.
OK, what does that mean?
I'm probably vulnerable to it.
What should I do to fix it?
Well that's easy, too.
NPM audit fix.
The great thing here
is if we can give you
a patched version of that
dependency without violating
your Semver requirements that
are in your package JSON,
we will do it.
And we will give you the fix
right here without out you
having to do anything
more than just that.
Fixed one vulnerability.
Now if I run NPM install, clean.
I'm in that green zone now.
I'm safe, I've patched.
MYLES BORINS: That's
really awesome.
And-- [APPLAUSE]
CJ SILVERIO: Yeah.
MYLES BORINS: Can you
tell me a little bit more
about how it knew that
there was a vulnerability?
CJ SILVERIO: We have taken
the Node security project
vulnerability
database-- which is
the collective work of the Node
ecosystem, which takes this
very seriously-- and
we've integrated that
in with NPM install.
So every time you do
a read of packages,
we have that security
data passed down.
Even if you're pulling
for your local cache
we can tell you that
we found something
that you didn't know about
last time you ran an install.
MYLES BORINS: That's
really amazing.
And then we were just talking
before about two factor
authentication.
I believe NPM has some
new stuff coming down
the pipeline for it?
CJ SILVERIO: Yes, we do.
The ESLint maintainers, who
also had a very bad week,
could have done a
couple of things
to protect themselves from it.
They could have turned on two
factor auth for all rights
so that any time
they typed publish
for any package they
own, they would have
to provide a one time password.
We've just rolled out
last week in response
to this a brand new feature
where you can protect
a package with two factor auth
so that any time any maintainer
publishes it, whether
they've turned on 2FA or not,
they have to enable it,
provide a one time password,
and install.
It is an inconvenience.
But if you published NPM,
please protect your packages.
If you are using a very highly
popular package, enable this.
And this is in the
NPMC [INAUDIBLE]
right now website,
you just flip it on.
MYLES BORINS: Wonderful.
Thank you so much, CJ.
CJ SILVERIO: You're welcome.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL MCDONALD: Cool,
so we saw right there
regular expression
denial of service.
How many people feel like they
know what denial of services
are?
A couple of them?
MYLES BORINS: Mike.
Mike.
MICHAEL MCDONALD:
Oh God, stop, stop.
I don't have time for this.
MYLES BORINS: OK.
MICHAEL MCDONALD: There you go.
So Myles just exhibited
a very classic example
of denial of service, right?
You have traffic coming
into your application,
and malicious traffic
then starts bothering you.
Maybe it's taking up
network resources,
or your CPU just hits 100%,
you can't do anything anymore.
You can't focus on
that task that you
were supposed to do earlier.
But there are also a
number of other kinds
of denials of service.
So the resource
exhaustion case that we
showed there of, say,
running out of network
or running out of CPU.
But you also have a couple of
other categories of things that
could cause denials of service.
The regular expression
DoS, for instance,
could be kind of
a code error issue
where maybe a well-formed
request comes in,
but it triggers some bug
in the code that ends up
creating a resource
exhaustion or maybe there's
other expensive computation.
So for instance, we
were doing crypto
on the main thread in Node
and basically DoSed ourselves.
And then my personal
favorite denial of service
is an economic
denial of service.
Where someone-- one of the
great things about Serverless
is that it scales infinitely.
You keep throwing
traffic at it and it
keeps scaling, which
potentially means
that it keeps billing you.
So if you have a budget set,
or there are quotas in place,
those could be throttling you.
So we showed the kind of classic
denial of service of a resource
exhaustion.
We'll now show a really fun
one, the hug of death of DoSing
yourself.
So you may have external
traffic coming in.
And as your Cloud
Functions are scaling up,
maybe they're writing
to that SQL database,
you run out of file descriptors.
Or there are some
other finite resources,
and you overload your
database, and it falls over.
So we have a really
cool new tool.
So scaling controls.
So again, it's really great to
have the infinite scalability
of functions as a service.
But sometimes,
because not everything
is serverless and
amazing under the hood,
you want to, say, limit to
only 100 functions can run.
Because you may only have 100
file descriptors or whatever.
There is some limiting
resource in the backend.
You can deploy your functions
with the max instances flag
and limit it.
So once you've done
that, your functions
will start scaling
up, and they'll
hit that max instances
limit and peter off.
So traffic, you'll start
providing back pressure
up to your clients.
Maybe the clients will force
retries or do something
like that.
But your database will be fine.
A quick note.
So we have a couple of
different Serverless products
within Google Cloud.
Functions is kind of
the main common one,
but we also have App Engine.
So App Engine, you're running
an application rather than
just a single function.
It has slightly different
scaling behavior.
So as your App Engine
app is scaling up,
it'll hit that max
instances limit.
But then it will also
start routing traffic back
to existing apps
because they can
continue serving that traffic.
So it will still provide
that scaling limit,
but the behavior will
be slightly different.
So just something
to take into account
if you're building an app on
App Engine versus Functions.
And then to prevent the kind
of economic denial of service
we can do budget alerts.
So you can actually
go into your project
and say, I want to be notified
anytime I hit 50%, 90%, 100%,
whatever percent you
want of your budget.
And my favorite
feature of this is
that you can actually then
trigger Cloud Functions off
of your budget alert.
So if you've got a budget
alert saying that your Cloud
Functions have
exceeded 100%, you
can trigger more
Cloud Functions.
Just a fun little thing.
But that is nice
because then you
could, say, trigger
a Cloud Function that
would kill an offending
process or otherwise shut down
resources or deny access.
That's a nice little
way of containing that.
MYLES BORINS: So a great way
to cause problems for yourself
is leaking credentials.
If any of you were
paying attention earlier,
you may have noticed
that I leaked
all of our database credentials
on screen to all of you.
Now, we're going to be shutting
that database down later.
But if you had been
paying attention,
you probably could have made
some problems for my demo.
But there are common
credentials and common ways
that you can leak it.
Database user and
password, as we saw,
is a really easy way to leak it.
Leaking it by writing
it right into your code.
That's a great way to
say that you accidentally
put it into your get repo,
you push it to GitHub.
There's bots that are constantly
doing static analysis of GitHub
to find these kinds
of credentials.
You can potentially
leak OAuth credentials.
This could happen by
potentially sending credentials
in a request not over HTTPS.
Anything that's in any of
those hops, if your credentials
are in plain text there, they
know not only your credentials,
but where you were
sending them to.
You can have credential leaks
through improper use of crypto.
And you can also,
as I was mentioning,
publish your credentials
accidentally somewhere
like GitHub or NPM.
Now, here's an example of
putting the credentials right
into your code.
One of the things that
you'll notice about this that
is particularly problematic
is this mysql.createPool call,
this is a pretty generic
way of making this call.
This is very
statically analyzable.
Bots can crawl, text--
we have BigQuery.
BigQuery lets you do this.
You can write parsers that
will go through and just find
this and leak the
credentials for you.
So one way that we've been
thinking about fixing this
and worked on fixing this
is a great new feature
called environment
variables, something
I'm really excited about.
You can now in the deployment
set environment variables
for your cloud functions.
You can also set them in
the UI when you deploy it.
By setting these
environment variables,
we then inside of our code
could reference the environment
variables rather
than referencing
the items themselves.
And now there is
absolutely no way
that we're going to be leaking
these credentials using
our code.
Now, this is not
foolproof, and we'll
dig into that in a minute.
But this is a huge step forward.
Now, if you didn't want to
put it into the environment
variables, there's
other ways that you can
be storing your credentials.
We have Cloud KMS, which
is cloud hosted keys.
You could use the
HashiCorp Vault.
We'll be showing some
other ways to do it.
So you don't need to put
it right into the process
into your environment variables,
but it is a really great step
that you can take without a
lot of engineering investment
to make your code more
secure right off the bat.
MICHAEL MCDONALD: I'm really
glad we didn't see anyone
get up and run out of the room.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, so we talked a
lot about credentials,
but there are also a number of
things in the authentication
realm of what you're doing
with those credentials
or how you're checking
those credentials that
can be potentially
problematic, especially
in a Serverless world.
So when we started, Myles
had a single function--
the save markdown function--
that went ahead and took
the markdown, parsed
HTML, wrote the database.
We decided good
code practices, we
wanted to split those in two.
We wanted to have a generic
markdown to HTML function,
because maybe we want to
send our HTML somewhere else.
And then we also
wanted to restrict
all that horrific
write to the database
passwords, and secrets, and code
into its own little separate
functions.
So that everyone in
the end user world
is not directly having
access to our database.
That was awesome
except for the fact
that all of these functions
are public on the internet.
So someone could simply bypass
all of our restrictions set up
in our markdown to HTML function
and write malicious HTML
directly into our database.
It's called execution
flow manipulation.
And as we move into a world
of micro services or nano
services--
I'm trying to make that catch
on, by the way, nano services--
as we move into that
world, these attacks
become much more
common, especially when
you have events--
you can imagine an event being
triggered from a Google Cloud
storage bucket
going to a function,
running to a database,
triggering another event.
There are a lot of little attack
vectors between those cracks.
So one of the new features
that we're announcing
is security controls
between functions.
So you can set an IAM
policy on a function that
lets you control access
from not only developers
but other functions
or other GCP services.
You could have GCE VM or an
App Engine app securely writing
to your function as well as
end users who have signed in
via Google sign in.
One of the other
things that we're doing
is we're starting to make
functions private by default.
So your HTTP functions
will no longer be
publicly available on
the internet the second
you deploy them.
Developers can still use the
command line to call them,
but you don't have to
release everything publicly
immediately.
So we're going to
add IAM policies
onto both of our functions.
The first one we're
going to say all users
can take this
special invoker role
to invoke our first function,
our markdown to HTML function.
And on the second
one, we're actually
going to say we've
given a service
account to our second
function and we're
going to say only our
first service account
and on our first function can
invoke the second function.
Otherwise, it's closed
off from the world.
So we have that kind
of IAM security barrier
between our functions,
and that would
prevent our malicious
content from coming
in to the second function.
But as I mentioned
earlier, we're
still making it easier
for developers to use it.
So if you're logged
into the command line,
you can deploy your function.
It's deployed privately,
but you can then just
say gcloud functions call
and call the function
as you normally would.
And that will take your
developer credentials,
pass them through, and let
you invoke that function.
So if you want to sign up for
this, it's in alpha right now.
So you can take a
photo of that, sign up,
and you can start
using it shortly.
Give everyone a second
to take a look at that.
Perfect.
So there's kind of
a parallel to that
of not only is there a
potential for malicious content
to come in, but there's
a really high potential
for the good content that you
have to leave your application.
So you can imagine,
for instance,
instead of a malicious call
coming in to your function,
you can imagine that someone
has maybe done a remote code
execution vulnerability
in one of your functions
and is trying to
exfiltrate data.
So they're going to take
all that markdown content
and send it to
their own endpoint.
So the evil.com example
down there below.
Or you can imagine
a similar thing
where someone has dumped the
process environment variables,
which--
and this is why we were
saying it's maybe not the best
idea to store all
of your secrets
in environment variables.
If someone could eval
console log process n
and say store that as
their name in the database,
they could then use
our second function
to pull all that HTML
content out of the database
without you knowing.
We're going to actually have
one of our partners come up
and talk about how to mitigate
those threats shortly.
MYLES BORINS: So joked
about this earlier,
but query injection
is real and alive.
So the code that I originally
wrote was pretty susceptible.
Here's a slightly
simplified version of it.
What you can see that we're
doing that's not so great
is we're building the query
manually from a string
and concatenating information
unsanitized that was
handed over from the internet.
And one of the things
that could happen here,
which would be kind
of bad, is someone
who knows how we have
it done internally--
or is guessing-- could hand
us off HTML that internally
is actually breaking
up the string
and including an extra SQL
call that is, in turn, deleting
all of our information.
That's no good.
We don't want that.
MICHAEL MCDONALD: No good.
MYLES BORINS: So we can
fix this by escaping.
And so one of the things
that's really great
is MySQL itself, the
module friend PM,
comes with an escape function.
This is not the same
as just calling escape
on the string in JavaScript.
It comes with a
escape function that's
going to properly
escape your data
to be put up into
MySQL so you can still
build the string without
worrying about doing it.
Now, while this is
better, there is best.
So we can avoid
sanitizing altogether
and rely on the library
to sanitize it for us.
You'll see the set question mark
syntax that we're using here.
This is taken directly
from the MySQL readme
as the preferred way
of posting information.
And what you can
see that we're doing
is we're building an
object in JavaScript.
We're passing that object
over to the MySQL library,
and we're allowing MySQL to
know how to actually convert
everything itself.
One of the things that's
really nice about this,
too, is not only is
it going to escape,
but it's going to
smartly escape.
So in the example
that I had originally,
I was taking a time stamp with
the JavaScript data object.
You can actually just pass
that directly this way
and it will sanitize and turn
the data object into the string
format that MySQL's expecting.
So not only are you removing
potential programming errors
from a security
standpoint, you're
removing programming
errors from just straight
up consistency and correct
way of programming.
So while the other way
of doing it yourself
works like anything in security,
if there's a way for you
to not do it, don't do it.
Let other people who
have done it right
and made the mistakes
before you do it instead.
With that, we're going to bring
up Devon Rifkin from Intrinsic.
Big round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
So Devon, can you tell us a
little bit about Intrinsic?
DEVON RIFKIN: Sure.
So Intrinsic is a runtime
enforcement system
where basically we want to
make it really easy for you
to choose exactly which
resources your Google Cloud
Functions can access.
And so when we talk about how
to get really good security,
you want to talk about
least privilege, which
is the idea that your
function should only
be able to do exactly what it
needs to do and nothing more.
And this is how we're
going to protect
against some of the issues that
Mike was talking about earlier.
So the way that Intrinsic
works is we actually
sit between the runtime
and all of your code.
So you've got both application
code and dependency code.
But what we let you do is we
let you put policies on that
so that when you try to go
to evil.com it doesn't work.
So now we're going to actually
look at some improved code,
sort of what we've
been showing before.
So this has some of the fixes.
This is the split out one.
So this is the first function,
and this one takes markdown,
and it turns it
into HTML, and then
it passes it to the
second function.
So when we think
about what privileges
does this function
need to do, it's
not really very much at all.
In fact, the only
thing it really does
is down here it just posts
to this post URL which
is just the second function.
So when we think about how we
want to restrict this function,
we really want it so that the
only thing it can possibly do
is talk to the second function.
So let's look at how we
do that with Intrinsic.
With Intrinsic you don't
change your code at all.
So you keep it the same.
And the policies, they
apply to all the code.
Even malicious code can't
get around the policies.
So we've got just a
single policy here
where what we do
is we say, hey, we
want to allow posting to
this particular URL which
corresponds to our
second function.
So let's go ahead and look at
what some malicious code might
look like.
So this is a little bit
of a contrived example,
we're just putting
in something that
changes the URL into evil.com.
But any of the
dependencies could do that.
Or if you had a remote code
execution vulnerability,
they could easily
exfiltrate the data.
So let's actually
run this function.
So we're going to
do a malicious call.
And this just uses the
gcloud functions call.
And now what's funny
here is it says error,
but that's actually good.
That's a good indication
that we're protected,
but let's take a
look at the logs
to make sure that that's true.
So here are the logs, and let me
make this a little bit bigger.
So we see that we tried
to post to evil.com
and Intrinsic blocked this.
So it said, hey, this
is a policy violation.
You tried to post to
evil.com, and that's not
in the white list.
So all the Intrinsic
policies, because we really
want to focus on the
principle of least privilege,
it's just all white list based.
You don't want to say
things you can't do,
you only want to say
the things you can do.
And this fits in super well
with how Serverless works,
where you have lots of nano--
what are we saying?
Nano services, right?
MICHAEL MCDONALD: Catching on.
DEVON RIFKIN: So this is
great, and this protects you.
And you can set up
notifications, alerts,
and stack driver
to notify your team
that something bad has happened,
something totally unexpected.
But in the meantime, your
data is completely safe.
So that's very good.
We're going to look at
the next function now.
So this is the second one.
And this one's
pretty interesting
because we have another piece
of sensitive data, which
is the database
password that Myles
leaked several times already.
So we've got these
environment variables set up,
which is pretty good.
That's pretty good.
So let's go ahead and run this.
And we're going to log
the environment variables.
So we'll run this right here.
So it inserted it with an ID 90.
I got rid of Myles' pass the
database results straight
through.
Don't want to do that.
So let's take a
look at the logs.
Yeah, so kind of as expected
my password is just there.
And so while this is a
lot better than storing it
in your code because that means
it shows up in fewer places,
it still could be exfiltrated.
Now, luckily, we're
using Intrinsic
so you can't just post it
to your own attacker server.
But Mike kind of
alluded to this before.
If the attacker's super
clever and they're
trying to really
target you, they
might just store
it in the database,
and then go to your blog and
see the password, and then
mess with it that way.
So they might exfiltrate
it another way.
So we've been working on
ways of preventing even
leaking it in special ways.
And what we've realized
is you don't actually
need to see the real
value in your code.
All you're doing is you're
passing along the password
to the MySQL database.
You're not operating
on the actual value.
So this is a new type
of policy that we've
introduced called tokenization.
And what it does is it
takes your real secrets--
so your database
passwords, or API keys,
or other sensitive user
data you can imagine.
Social security numbers,
you don't really
need to do math on them.
It turns them into
dummy tokens when
it's running in the
untrusted code area, which
is where all your code runs.
a that means both your
code and third party code
never see the actual value.
Then on the way out,
we check to make sure
that you're connecting to the
thing that we expect you are.
And if you are, we'll
translate it to the real value.
But your code never, ever
sees the real secret,
and that means it's impossible
for that code to leak it.
So let's see what that
policy might look like.
So it's super easy.
Again, we don't change
any of our code.
And we've got a single
tokenization policy here
where we say, hey, we've
got this environment
variable called db password.
We want to tokenize it.
And then we want to detokenize
it only when it goes to MySQL,
and only when it matches exactly
this user database and socket
path.
We don't want somebody to
try to steal it by faking
making another MySQL server.
And then again, you
don't change any code.
We've got a single policy.
We don't need to
make any HTTP calls.
So let's go ahead and run this.
So we run this and it's
looking pretty good.
We do have ID 91, so we're
inserting more things.
Let's take a look at the logs.
And this is great.
So instead of the
real password, it
shows tokenized by Intrinsic.
So if an attacker wants to
steal that fake password,
let them do it.
It's fine.
And most importantly,
it still was
able to post to the MySQL
database and insert it.
So it worked transparently
but kept you safe.
And so we're really excited
about these tokenization
policies, because they
let you just get rid
of whole classes of attacks.
And it's really flexible.
It's not just environment
variables in MySQL databases.
The sources might be HTTP
responses, or the file system,
or database entries.
And it might go to
database entries
where you want to store
things that you never
were able to see.
And you might detokenize
the particular HTTP requests
if you're using API keys,
and even responses to users.
So let's say that you
pull a social security
number from the database.
Your app code never needs to see
it if it's just displaying it
to the user.
So we're really
excited to have people
start using these policies.
We think it's going to
really help protect things.
And thanks, that's what I got.
MYLES BORINS: Thank
you so much, Devon.
That was really great.
[APPLAUSE]
So we've kind of gone
through a whole class
of errors that are mostly
solved through programming
and engineering.
But engineering is
not just about code.
If you are running
a team, if you
are thinking about the
process of your organization,
there's a whole class
of vulnerabilities
that can come in
because developers just
don't have time to deal
with all of your policies.
If all of your different
security policies
that you have in place make
for bad developer experiences,
your developers may end
up working around that
and making things
even more vulnerable
than you started with.
Some examples of poor
developer experience
include certain kinds
of shared environments.
Having dev, staging,
and prod all
use the same database
means that all
of your different environments
have the same restrictions when
writing to the database,
which may mean that you have
to jump through certain hoops.
MICHAEL MCDONALD: Or they don't.
MYLES BORINS: Or don't, yeah.
And you can end up
with unreviewed code
into production.
So one thing that you can
do is enforce isolation
and use a deployment manager
to replicate environments
to make sure that
you're not getting
the wrong things
in the wrong place
or doing things you don't want.
One of the biggest
problems that can
happen for people is a slower
manual toolchain, having
to manually deploy everything,
having it be really slow
introduces lots of
errors in edge cases.
Using things like
continuous integration
and continuous deployment
can really help fix that.
There's a really awesome
tool called Spinnaker
which runs on top
of Kubernetes that
helps you run all this stuff.
We also have Cloud Builder
is one of our products
that you can use for automating
the process of Docker.
If you go and look at
the node sec roadmap,
some of the stuff in there
that I particularly enjoyed
was some of the thoughts on
how to separate environments
and creating different
levels of policy
for different environments.
So for example, your
developers can maybe
use any module that they want
to use while they're in dev.
And when they move to
staging, your security team
can start auditing them and
then actually send it back
to dev if some of
those don't meet
the level of quality that's
needed to reach production.
What this does is
it kind of flips it.
Instead of creating this really
strict policy saying, hey,
you can't use
anything right now,
it allows your devs to run
really fast, get the things
that they need to do
done to figure out
how to solve the problem.
And then, once they figured
out those abstractions, on Node
there's so many different
modules available in NPM.
So if we use
marked, for example,
and that DoS wasn't fixed
yet, and they're like,
oh no, you need another
markdown parser,
there's seven other
markdown parsers.
Our security team can even come
up with three or four examples
that we can switch to.
But that doesn't stop the
velocity of your team.
And so instead of creating
problems, we're creating work.
It's not, hey,
you can't do this.
It's like, hey,
here's another ticket.
By changing that
story a little bit,
we change the way the
developers are working.
And instead of breaking
velocity, we improve velocity.
This moves all the way through
your whole process down to how
you're handling to a thing.
You need to make sure that
the process that you have
in place has buy-in
from your team's
and is not hurting
velocity, but that doesn't
mean that you compromise.
And this is a balance
that's hard to find.
But what we're hoping is,
with all the different things
that we remove by moving
you to Serverless,
that you're able to focus on
more laser focused policies,
more laser focused workflows,
and can create a velocity
that your team's on board with.
And you end up with much
more secure apps at the end.
[MUSIC PLAYING]